lui aussi a subi personnellement irma et
ses conséquences alors c'était ma
résidence le pirate de toit s'est envolé
sur les deux tiers
on a tous eu des dégâts sur nos sur nos
maisons sur nos voitures et il a fallu
jongler entre le travail et la vie
personnelle trouver à manger trouver de
l'eau les premiers jours ont été assez
difficiles lorsque son emploi du temps
le permet le vice-procureur rejoint sa
femme christine pour nettoyer leur
appartement dans cet immeuble en bord de
mer durement touchée par le cyclone
voilà ce qui reste de la piscine et le
mur de clôture
il ya une vague de six à huit mètres là
qui s'est abattue oui c'était bien pour
travailler ici c'était agréable mais on
va continuer différemment yves paillard
loger dans cet appartement au premier
étage
dès son arrivée sur l'île inondé le soir
dire ma part plusieurs mètres d'eau le
logement du vice procureur est depuis
inhabitable c'est infestés de moustiques
et de mouches les meubles pour hisser
l'immeuble et pas sécurisé et au dessus
quand il pleut
ça goûte puisqu'il ya plus de toit au
dessus donc c'est pas c'est pas salubre
en attendant les travaux le couple est
logé dans une petite chambre d'hôtel
malgré son statut
aucune aide particulière de l'état ne
lui a été apportée c'est difficile il ya
déjà des tensions il ya de la
promiscuité parce qu'on est dans un tout
petit espace et des moments difficiles
on pouvait pas se doucher pendant des
jours on portait toujours les mêmes
vêtements ont mangé des rations
militaires giné pouces courageuse qui a
pas voulu partir en métropole qu'à pas
choisi la facilité il a déjà charge
devant l'ampleur du phénomène des
pillages le vice procureur n'a pas voulu
quitter l'île avec des collègues et les
gendarmes sur place une cellule de crise
a immédiatement été montée il y avait
des bandes de pillards qui circulait
sans arrêt donc on a senti ce besoin de
sécurité et on s'est dit on peut pas on
peut pas laisser les choses comme ça il
faut organiser la riposte et la
gendarmerie a bien réagi et avait une
structure qui permettait de bien
s'organiser
donc nous on est restés pour pour donner
l'appui pour que la chaîne pénale soit
pas cassée sur le plan personnel
yves paillard et sa femme se sont sentis
livrés à eux mêmes en tant qu ancien
policier
il a alors pris des mesures radicales
pour assurer leur propre protection
j'ai pris une arme un soir j'ai demandé
aux gendarmes ils ont besoin pour passer
la nuit si oui les problèmes ne sont pas
résolus
tout va dépendre de ce fascicule
redémarre si les commerces doivent
vous c'est vrai que les commerces qui
ouvrent ça peut être une tentation pour
des petits braqueurs pour aller chercher
des fonds de caisse